but how does it apply to dating and  advice and all of that what's the  dynamic there  how does it apply to date well so like  gosh there's so much that goes into it  but it's just like women so for example  they study women like and why women do  the things they do so like women look  for different things at different ages  so like for example women one thing they  talk about is a woman's sexual market  value so like when she's at her highest  and what she would look for when she's  the most attractive to men so for  example  women in their early 20s tend to look  for looks well women in their late 20s  to 30s tend to look for security and  that so they would say like these are  the examples and yeah